now I'll have to see whether the
microphone works so very good thank you
correct for the very nice introduction
and thank you for coming so in such a
large number despite finals going on
meeting of the minds a computer science
Distinguished Lecture in parallel and
the Penguins game are starting very soon
so well we want to talk about science
that tonight using the release of the
angels and demon movie next week so the
movie is scheduled to come out end of
next week I've not seen the movie so I
do hear it's there quite a few things
that are different there compared with
the book but all the reference that I'm
going to use is based on Dan Brown's
book and my memory of reading this book
a few years ago okay so to get everybody
up to speed I thought I went in case
there are some here who are not so
familiar with with the story i thought i
will start with showing you the trailer
for the for the movie no okay I guess it
was seen for alright here we go
okay let's see what this all works here
to be selected we are under attack from
an old enemy find professor London he
exposed one of the greatest cover-ups in
human history
but what terrifying discovery would make
the Vatican turn to him
that's Illuminati the Illuminati were a
secret society dedicated to scientific
truth the Catholic Church ordered a
brutal Massacre the silenced them
forever they've come for their revenge
is a hidden trail through Rome itself
I need access to the Vatican archives
access to the archives is only by
Tristram decree by the Holy Father
fellas you called me this is the first
time what sort of sign earth air fire
water and a fifth sign may God forgive
you for what you've done
father God has issues they won't be with
what we've done
they'll be with what we're about to do
our church is at war
this is the first marker the path is
alive
you're talking about the moment of
creation
open the doors and tell the world the
truth
it has to be there
this is it
this is the truth angels and demons so
this is how so many pictures advertises
as a movie now where's here the science
to me this sort of appears like a movie
about the Vatican the Catholic Church a
Pope to be elected and old Brotherhood a
Harvard simple Oh chest raising through
Rome
so where's versa here the the science
maybe let's start with taking a brief a
look how our scientists are usually a
portrait in movies so if we go back so
one of the first scientists who came to
very a famous a recognition in movie was
a dr. Frankenstein who created a monster
very similar theme is in something like
dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
so then when time went on scientists
became even more destructive especially
after World War two and with the arc
onset of the hydrogen bomb the atomic
bomb
so there are scientists like a doctor no
the arch evil of James Bond and even in
cartoons like Superman somebody like Lex
Luthor uses some kind of a science to
give Superman a hard time well nowadays
we have science on TV like in this show
numbers what do the scientists do they
solve crime scene investigations and
there is also sort of TV shows like that
one here that I have never seen also it
is about to a particle physicists who
are trying their knowledge in a real
life
so based on this I would say scientists
in movies their role is to create
monsters destroy the world perform a
crime scene investigation and they're of
course good for some laughs however very
rarely scientists do in movies what they
really do in real life which is to study
the secrets of nature and to study the
laws of nature so let's see what Ron
Howard has to say about the science in
angels and demons so I'm showing you
another short clip our church is at war
we are under attack from an old enemy
one of the main themes in angels and
demons of course is the age-old struggle
between science and religion for
centuries scientists have been trying to
understand so many aspects of our world
including the moment of creation it's a
way of studying the origins of the
universe what some people call the god
particle the nature of the controversy
is discussed all the time and if science
has been on this one track and faith and
theology is on another track science and
religion are not enemies there are
simply some things that science is too
young to understand centuries ago the
Catholic Church did persecute scientists
who were developing ideas that they
thought were progressive and that the
church found threatening since the days
of Galileo this church has tried to slow
the relentless march of progress in
angels and demons the Illuminati have
resurfaced and are using cutting-edge
science to threaten to destroy about
sage and honey thread destruction of
Vatican City through light
my character believes in the church and
if science is able to claim creation
then what he says at one point was left
for God science and religion may never
see eye to eye and yet we're all
struggling to understand our universe
better it's that pressure that Dan Brown
understands it gives angels and demons
somatic richness it's thought-provoking
all right so it's about science and
religion now this is a very heavy topic
which is way beyond my pay scale so I
will just I will just focus on the
science and not talk about religion so
we will talk about science and leave the
religion for for right now as it is so
the the main plot in the end the movie
and also in the book that relates to
science is that antimatter is stolen
from CERN it is created with the Large
Hadron Collider and it is a hidden in a
vatican city where it is acts as a
ticking time bomb that is going off in
the countdown to the destruction and an
inhalation of varakin starts which then
results in a big race through a rome to
avert death and destruction so there is
talk about about CERN and so this is
Hollywood's image of CERN this is a
screenshot from from from the movie in
the book CERN is described as a
semi-private laboratory which is sort of
portrayed as a small city with of course
laboratories but also supermarkets a
hospital a movie theater and most
importantly recreational shooting
arranged
now let me tell you the real CERN there
is not really a hospital there's no
movie theater and there's certainly no
recreational shooting range so what
about at the the real CERN
so if you look very closely if you paid
attention in the interview with Ron
Howard if we zoom in here a little bit
we will see if we go very close that on
his head he actually wears the logo of
CERN so he's actually wearing a real
CERN kappa here okay so the real CERN is
at the European laboratory for particle
physics it's near Geneva in Switzerland
it was founded in 1954 20 European
countries are member state it hosts more
than 9,000 scientists who come from over
a hundred nationalities and countries
and they are also a more than 1,000
scientists from the United States who do
their research there at CERN so this is
here a aerial view of the of the CERN
side and it shows sort of most of most
of the laboratory and I'll let you a
church weather can be a cold in a small
city sir hosts the Large Hadron Collider
which is the largest particle
accelerator in the world it has a it is
sort of indicated here as this red line
it has a circumference of 27 kilometers
which is about 16 miles
it goes through France and Switzerland
it is in a tunnel underground about 100
meters underground and so you see here
the the area so this is here over here
very small is the Sarang site that we
just saw just as a reference this is
here the Geneva Airport loop may make
out the the runway this is a part of
Lake Geneva here and in the back is one
plot the highest known
in Europe that you can see on a clear
day from from CERN the LHC is it's a
Collider where there are four
experiments that are going into an
operation their names are Ellis Atlas
LHC P and then there is the CMS
experiment which stands for a compact
muon solenoid and this is the experiment
I'm working with and so later on I will
tell you a little bit about the physics
and we will focus about focus on the CMS
experiment now in the in the LHC protons
travel in this 27-kilometer ring and
they go around they're about eleven
thousand times a second with a speed
that is 99 point and then 8/9 follow of
the speed of light there are two beams
of protons where each beam has a energy
of what we call a 7 TeV in the T stands
for forterra this is 10 to the 12 like
trillion that we are now familiar from
our from our federal budget and the e V
the e V stands for electron world so
this is the energy that an electron gets
if it crosses a potential of one world
the energy of the protons in the India
LHC is comparable to a 400-ton train
like the the tertiary the the French
high-speed train going with a speed of
about 100 miles per hour so there's a
lot of energy that is going to be stored
in this beam of the of the LHC the the
beam is kept with these blue magnets
here on its circular path they are about
1232 of these magnets in the in the ring
each magnet is about 15 meters long and
weighs about 30 30 tons and all these
the magnets were brought down through a
100 meter deep chef
into the into the tunnel and then
assembled these magnets produce a
magnetic field of about eight Tesla this
is a very very high magnetic field that
is needed to keep the protons on this
circular path and they are operated at
these are superconducting magnets and
they are operated at a temperature of
1.9 Kelvin and the coil of these in of
these magnets they are made out of 36
strands and one of these strands is
shown here in in a cross-section it's
the Strand is about one and a half
centimeters wide and it consists of
about 6,400 filaments of niobium
titanium these filaments themselves are
very very thin like something like seven
microns this is like a tenth of the of
the thickness of a hair so if you
unraveled all these all these filaments
and light them out you could go from the
earth to the Sun ten ten times quite a
lot of material that is in the use here
in this accelerator so it of course you
know takes a lot of a power to operate
at the the LHC the power consumption is
about 120 mega watt which is sort of the
power consumption of the city of Geneva
which is which is a nearby and so you
can imagine this is results and in quite
in some electricity bill at the end of
the year which is in the order of 20 to
30 million dollar okay very good
okay so now let's go back to our angels
and demons and to look a little bit more
closely at the at the science there
which has to do with antimatter and so I
will show you another video clip and
here we go
where is that camera number 86 it's
wireless 82 was stolen he could be
anywhere inside the vet that canister
contains the extremely combustible
substance called antimatter we need to
locate it immediately or evacuate
Vatican City I'm quite familiar with
incendiary space veteran I've never
heard of antimatter being used as such
well it's never been generated in
significant quantities before it's a way
of studying the origins of the universe
to try to isolate what some people call
the god particle but there are
implications for energy research
particle what we call it isn't important
it's what gives all matter mass the
thing without which we could not exist
you're talking about the moment of
creation yes ma'am the antimatter is
suspended there in an airtight nano
composite shell with electro magnets in
each end but if it were to fall out of
suspension and come in contact with
matter say the bottom of the canister
then the two opposing forces would
annihilate one another violently what
might cause it to fall out a suspension
the battery going dead which it will in
six hours kind of annihilation how
violent a cataclysmic event a blinding
explosion equivalent to about 5
kilohertz Vatican City will be consumed
by my very good so what now what is this
antimatter is it the what fuels of the
warp drive of the USS Enterprise in Star
Trek
well no antimatter is is real it does
exist it is produced for example at the
Large Hadron Collider and enough of it
really could destroy Vatican City and
and also a big parts of of Rome so what
is this antimatter well in order to
answer this question let's start first
with a simpler question which is what is
matter so our building blocks of matter
so our current understanding of matter
is they're based on there are what we
call elementary particles named quarks
there are six of them
they have names like oops like up or a
down quark there's a strange quark charm
quark bottom quark and the top quark and
then along with these six quark they go
leptons where the electron is it's
probably the one that you all are
familiar with but the electron has
heavier partners so there's a muon and a
towel and along with these leptons they
have partners they are called neutrinos
these are very elusive particles that
are for example created in the fusion a
process in the in the Sun and many many
of them go through you every every
seconds but they don't really do
anything because they very very rarely
interact with with matter and so if you
want to build what is around us all we
need is an up quark a down quark and and
an electron so - with the up and a down
quark we can put two up quarks and one
down quark and I built a proton we can
put two tongue works and one up work to
build a neutron and then as you know
protons and neutrons they form the
atomic nucleus and if we then put some
electrons and let them run around we
have an atom and then we just need to
multiply this by billions and billions
and billions and billions in order to
build something like a planet or put
something like a Sun and a galaxy and
the whole universe Sophia so that was a
matter so now what about the the
antimatter well for every a particle
that we that we know that is a matter
particle there is a partner which is
called its anti a particle so we have
for a for an up quark we have an end I
up for an electron we have a and I
electron but it's actually called a
positron because it has a positive
charge and the electron has as you all
know a negative charge
then we have a down quark and in that
town and an electron neutrino and an
entire electron neutrino now what's the
difference between particles and
antiparticles well they have the same
properties so they have the same mass
the only difference is they do have
opposite electric charge so as I already
said the electron is negatively charged
and the positron is positively charged
and these quarks are they have a
fractional charge so like the up quark
has a plus 2/3 of the electrons at
charge and then and I up would then have
minus 2/3 of the of the electron charge
or well okay all right so now what what
happens if matter and antimatter come
close to each other so the and I Tom
Hanks would very much look like a Tom
Hanks so if we put you know if you made
Tom Hanks out of antimatter he would
look exactly the same has the same
properties and if you didn't know it you
know you would not know that he is made
out of antimatter the only issue is when
they meet when they meet what is going
to happen is that the matter and
antimatter any light and they Ana he
laid into energy so what Tom Hanks said
that you know this is the old threat
Vatican City is destroyed by light is
exactly correct
the antimatter would annihilate and
release a lot of energy for example in
forms of in form of light and this is
all based on the probably most famous a
formula in the world he is a sea squirt
that energy and matter in form of mass
are equivalent and this is of course
Albert Einstein edits at his best
ok so let's go back to our angels and
demons and the and the antimatter ok so
the story was that Rome is threatened
and it in the book it says threatened by
crumb gram of antimatter but that's
about a quarter of a $1 bill which I
learned has raised about one gram okay
so let's do the math here so here is a
sea squirt so we have here our quarter
gram of antimatter C is the speed of
light that we are need to square and
then I put a factor of two here this
factor of two is is needed because the
quarter gram of antimatter is going to
annihilate with a quarter gram of matter
so the total energy that is will be
released is you know a quarter gram plus
a quarter gram of matter and antimatter
and so if you are calculate this you
will get a forty-five at trillion this
is again our 10 to the 12 that we had
before
Jules well Jules is an unit for energy
that people are familiar with who watch
their a diet it's not very convenient to
use tools for you know if something if
some a lot of energy is released
especially in a you know type of
explosion so there and at energy measure
are measured in like kilo tons of TNT
so 1 kiloton of TNT corresponds to four
point to a trillion joules so that makes
our math are quite quite simple because
the annihilation of our water current
meta with the aquatic Ram and I matter
is equivalent to about ten kilotons of
TNT that will set a reference the hero
the bomb dropped on Hiroshima was
estimated to correspond to about 14 kilo
tons of of TNT so the antimatter in the
book is more than enough to destroy the
very can and the surrounding area if you
paid attention in this previous movie
clip Victoria Petra the lady she talked
about it corresponds to 5 kilo tons of
and so it looks like the you know Dan
Brown did his math are quite correct
however he forgot about this factor of 2
that you actually have
you know you need the same amount of
matter to a nahi late at the the end I
have never okay now do we produce
antimatter I already told you yes it is
produced at the Large Hadron Collider
the largest producer of antimatter right
now is actually a near Chicago it's a
Fermilab a National Laboratory out there
in the western suburbs and there
antimatter is produced in by
accelerating a particles and just let
them collide with with some matter and
then filtering out at the the antimatter
particles and the amount of antimatter
that Fermilab creates a per year is
about two and nano grams so nano is ten
to the minus nine so this is a very very
very small amount of antimatter so that
would correspond if I did the math
correctly to about 86 grams of explosive
power of TNT I mean you might not want
to have this under your chair but it
wouldn't do too much to the Vatican
probably now in now in order to to
produce like a quarter gram it would
take something like a million years so
that's probably a time that even the
ancient a brotherhood might not want to
have wait for now it takes a lot of
power to to create this this antimatter
because you sort you have to run a
vehicle Eider and as we already said
before like the LHC you know it consumes
a lot of a lot of power so to run the
Tevatron Collider which is the largest
Collider at at Fermilab for a straight
for one year well that's not really in
reality because it's colliders they do
have some down times but if you do this
it well it would cost again a lot of
money but the electricity that is used
to run the the Tevatron for for year one
year you can convert this into an
explosive power of several hundred kilo
tons so if you just used the electricity
and wanted to
create a bomb with that that would be
quite easier way to go then to first
create a antimatter and then hide it
somewhere underneath the very cannon
okay so I thought antimatter is not
really a threat as I yes I think I was
able to show you how to create and I
matter you need much much much much much
more energy than is produced so it's
unfortunately also not a future energy
source because you know it takes much
much more energy to create the
antimatter then you is released by
letting it annihilate with real matter
so the only way to use it as an energy
source is if you found somewhere you
know in maybe it isn't a galaxy or
something like this you know some
antimatter then we could use it sort of
in the same way we use a coal or oil
that we find underneath the earth to do
a burn it and for for energy the other
thing it's not really a portable so this
is victoria veteran showing this little
a canister that is stolen from cern and
hidden under in Vatican City this is the
picture of a real anti-matter experiment
this is the Athena experiment at CERN
where anti hydrogen atoms are / -
they're produced so this was a
antiproton together with a project
positron to form a real hydrogen atom
and anti hydrogen atom and they produced
ten thousands hundred thousands but you
see it's quite a complex apparatus now
maybe one day you know technology will
advance and one can use something like
this to carry antimatter I we will have
to see
okay so since we reddit I thought I
won't think that I sort of fascinated me
a little bit when reading the Angels &
Demons book was that some of the science
is sort of somewhat accurate but then
there's quite a lot of science that is
not very accurate so since we reddit I
thought I'll discuss a few other science
fiction effects and fiction with you so
one thing is the the place where this
antimatter is a stone is from a
laboratory of a scientist who has his
laboratory right down in the in the
Large Hadron Collider and the tunnel
next to the accelerator well that
doesn't really work because of radiation
issues so the scientists would not have
survived for - along down there the
other the other issue is it's sort of
described as that you know he's
performing this really you know
top-secret research not even the CERN
director knows about it even so he uses
up like 80 or 90 percent of the budget
of CERN that so that is not really what
would happen in you know in reality you
know all you know scientific projects at
CERN are you know reviewed and
everything is of course public so
there's no classified research or
anything and everything is going to be
published okay another thing that comes
up is that the world wide web was
invented at CERN well that actually is
true so in 1989 Tim berners-lee
came up with the idea of and then
developed this what is now the HTTP
protocol which is what the world wide
web is based upon and there was just
when was it CERN I think in March when I
was at certainly was a little a
symposium of 20 years of world wide web
ok another fact this is one of my
favorites
so the asunder his name is in the book
Maximilian Kola a German scientist what
described as a being in a
wheelchair which of course associates to
another very brilliant scientists in a
wheelchair Stephen Hawking however in
the book via CERN a director he's
described as being bald and like you
know putting a lot of fear into into a
people so he's maybe a little bit more
like a dr. evil from from Austin Powers
well this is here the the current a
certain director his name is Rolf did
hire you see he has some hair he
actually is a chairman but the previous
restaurant director he was French the
one before was Italian and before him
the one was British
one more thing oops there is this X 33 a
space plane that Prince Robert Langdon
from Boston in a short amount of time
over to a certain it's sort of described
as you know the director uses it Prince
of the physicists to the laboratory
would be very nice
that's of course not not exist you know
people at CERN everybody you know flies
flies coach in the CERN director you can
ask my former student she said a next to
him on an airplane I going out to a
conference so everybody just you know
flies a coach without a space plane okay
so alright so there are more effect on
fiction in in the book but I thought
this is sort of where I want to stop
here with sort of digesting and the
science in the book and I thought I will
sort of next go and talk about some real
science that is done at at CERN and also
at at Fermilab and to sort of wrap this
up I thought I'd show you sort of a
little I guess PR video that CERN uses
to sort of promote themselves so this
gives actually good summary of what we
sort of talked
already here okay
CERN is the world's largest particle
physics research laboratory it covers
six square kilometers scattered over 12
sites either side of the Franco Swiss
border near Geneva in 34 kilometers of
tunnels and caverns the size of
cathedrals at over a hundred metres
underground CERN hosts facilities for
experimental physics scientists from all
over the world work here in
international collaborations to study
and understand the mysteries of the
universe stars planets seas air humans
everything around us is made of matter
matter is made of atoms atoms are made
of electrons orbiting around a nucleus
which in turn is made of protons and
neutrons inside these we find quarks in
CERN's newest accelerator the Large
Hadron Collider due to start operation
in 2008 particles will collide at nearly
the speed of light to study the quarks
and other particles many of these
particles only existed in the early
universe for a fraction of a second
after the Big Bang when all the energy
transformed into matter concerns
accelerators we can recreate conditions
that existed just after the Big Bang and
shed light on such questions as why do
particles have mass what is the nature
of dark matter in the universe
why did matter triumph over antimatter
in the first moments of the universe
making our existence possible what was
the state of matter just after the Big
Bang four gigantic instruments called
particle detectors will study the data
from the LHC collisions in search of the
answers to these fundamental questions
the experimental and theoretical study
of these conditions allows us to
understand the fundamental laws of
nature and to unveil the ultimate
mysteries that govern our universe in
the course of their research
CERN scientists have often come across
discoveries that have affected our
everyday life the technology used for
particle detectors is at the origin of
security scanning equipment and several
medical applications and the world wide
web was invented at CERN in 1990 by the
British scientist Tim berners-lee the
web soon grew beyond the world of
particle physics and has become a
primary repository of information
changing and improving the way people
interact and communicate to treat these
massive amounts of data produced by the
Large Hadron Collider physicists
together with experts from industry are
building a web of cooperative computing
called the grid the grid will allow
thousands of research centers and
universities to share their data storage
resources and computing power
transforming the internet into a giant
global supercomputer and building
capacity for the science of tomorrow
okay so with this nice summary of what
actually happens at CERN let's go back
to the to the real science and talk a
little bit about what antimatter is
actually used for so one application of
antimatter is through a PET scan and
maybe some of you had had a a PET scan
it stands for positron emission
tomography and what happens in a PET
scan is that the patient is injected
through IV usually into the blood system
certain amount of sugar and this the
sugar molecules are topped with a
radioactive substance typically a carbon
11 or fluoride 18 and so once this sugar
gets into the into the body what happens
is the sugar goes to the areas of very
high metabolism for example so where a
lot of sugar is consumed and it sort of
shows areas where you know there is a
lot of activity in the in the body now
what happens with the radioactive
substance that's attached to the sugar
molecules well it does a radioactive
decay and in this decay a positron and
antimatter particle is is released and
this and this positron very very quickly
within a smaller distance of like one
millimeter finds an electron from the
surrounding tissue and annihilates with
that with that electron and it initial
eights into two into two photons and
these two photons emerge back-to-back so
but what one finds is two to the
coincidence of two photons that are
registered like back to back and then
many of these one can then create a
three-dimensional image where you see
here this is an image of a human brain
or here you see sort of a real a
three-dimensional image where there's a
lot of activity around the stomach area
then of course the other what antimatter
can be used for its as you heard in the
in the a certain video is to solve some
of the biggest mysteries in science so
this is you know what is the origin of
the universe why do we have a mass and
what is the universe made of and I have
to tell you it is not made of antimatter
now how do we know that that is some
question I can't really get into why why
there is a no antimatter in the in the
universe but I want to talk a little bit
about how come that all the antimatter
in the universe disappeared in order to
do that and to discuss this matter
antimatter asymmetry in the universe
let's sort of rewind time go very far
back to the to the Big Bang so we are
here at a time of 10 to the minus 43
seconds right after after the Big Bang
the universe is very very very very very
hot and what we have is we have
particles we have NEP particles and then
we have energy and what happens is that
you know the particles and other
particles and he light into our energy
and out of the energy particles and
antiparticles are created and this all
maintains its balance but then the the
universe expands and a little at time
later it's not really very much from 10
to the minus 43 to 10 to the minus 33
which is sort of right after what is
called right after the inflationary
period where the universe vents were
very very very rapid growth at that time
a tiny asymmetry develops between matter
and antimatter and this asymmetry is
very very very small like for every 10
billion and that particles there is one
more particle okay so we just have a
very very tiny imbalance between
particles and and I particles now what
happens then you know the universe keeps
expanding it further cools down which
means that the energy of the of the
radiation here
less and less and at some point it chops
be below some threshold we're out of
this energy you can no longer create you
know a quirk or an antiquark or you
cannot no longer create a electron and a
positron so at some point you know when
the expansion of the universe goes on
you cannot create particles and their
particles anymore but the you know the
anti particles and the particles that
are still there they continue to
annihilate into into a radiation and
what is then left over is this tiny
excess of of matter which is then what
what we are what the universe is that
that you see out there and a lot of
radiation and this radiation then when
the universe further expands and expands
is what we now call the Cosmic Microwave
Background
which is a 2.7 Kelvin background
radiation which was discovered in 1954
by Penzias and Wilson now we talked
about the fact that there has to be a
small asymmetry between a matter and
antimatter now in particle physics that
we know there is a a small symmetry that
was discovered in 1964 so there's an
effect that sort of breaks the symmetry
between matter and antimatter and we
call this CP violation
CNP are sent sent for a to as symmetries
in physics as C stands for a charge
conjugation so this means if I apply a
charge communication I just turned the
charge of a particle into its opposite
charge which is sort of the same as I
turn a particle into its anti particle
which as we have learned has opposite
charge and P is a parity it's it means
that if a process happens from left to
right it can also happen from light
right to left and actually turns out not
all the laws of physics are invariant
under this transformation so in 1964 mr.
Cronin and Fitch I discovered CP
violation and they I got the Nobel Prize
nineteen eighty this is here this the
paper that they published if you look up
there you will see there are two other
people listed a mr. Kristensen Anna mr.
Charlie who were the the poster candy I
credit a student on that experiment for
some reason they were not really not
included in the world of Z a Nobel price
so don't ask me about that
okay so then thought this was a forty
years ago CP violation was discovered in
the decay of these particles that we are
caught they are called K ons in the
meantime more you know researcher has
gone on and so after forty years of
research
you now know that some particles behave
differently from there ndaya particles
we know that the difference is very very
small and it actually turns out this
difference between matter and antimatter
the CP violation that we measure in a
particle physics is too small and not
enough to explain the asymmetry in the
in the universe so there must be another
explanation and so what do we do well of
course oops
okay so we keep doing a more research
and on the next slide I thought I'll
show you a little bit our local
antimatter research teams so this is
about some research I was involved with
the CDF experiment at Fermilab two years
ago and this is where we measured how a
particle turns into its anti particle
and it does this at a very very high
frequency like three trillion times a
second so this was a very important
result that actually made the New York
Times so you see here it says here
physicists at the Fermi National
Accelerator order bla bla bla a
subatomic particle that reverses
identity three trillion times the second
switching into its upside-down mirror
image evil twin antimatter opposite and
then back okay
the real physics result can be sort of
illustrated in this diagram
so this shows here like the the
probability of the particle being a meta
particle which is your like plus 1 and
the probability of being an antimatter
particle which is like minus 1 and this
is shown versus time so you see this
particle you know turns from it's a
matter particle into its end a particle
and a back end and this repeats so that
was something I was involved in two
years ago and right now I'm working on
research that measures also CP violation
in particles that have a bottom quark in
the strange a quark and this was here at
is shown in the Fermilab result of the
week beginning of last year and it
starts here with the universe is a
strange place but what I want to bring
your attention to is here the people on
the on the Left which are our local
antimatter researchers so the gentlemen
to the right here is Chopra draw his
professor at the University of
Pittsburgh this is Karen Gibson she was
a former CMU credit student one of my
accredited students she is now at at
Pitt the gentleman here he was a credit
student at Pitt
he's now postdoc at CMU this gentleman
here he was a my student here at assume
you he is now what actually he's not a
postdoc at Pitt he is a postdoc at Johns
Hopkins there's another graduate student
from MIT and these are some German
collaborators okay so now the remaining
10-15 minutes I would like to say a
little bit about the research that we
plan to do it at CERN with the CMS
experiment so as I said the name CMS
stands for the compact muon solenoid so
it's a very compact experiment it is
about 15 meters high 15 meters wide and
about over 20 meters along when it's all
put together you see here a view where
some of the components are taking a part
it it weighs about 12,000 tons
the Iran that's mainly in the return
yoke of the of the magnet so there's a
very large magnet here the gray the gray
a barrel the magnet in the return yoke
is sorry the metal I'm sorry the metal
in the in the return New York of the
magnet is more iron than what is in the
in the Eiffel Tower in Paris and this
our magnet here the a solenoid it
creates a magnetic field of five Tesla
let's see what else might be worse to
tell you it costs about half a five
hundred million dollars said put this
all together
and they're about two thousand
physicists working on this experiment
and I'm just one of them all right so as
I wanted to show you a few pictures this
is here the picture of the absolute
solenoid the superconducting magnet you
see this is a very very large magnet so
quite a little bit bigger than the
magnets you have when you get an MRI
this is here you know some of the a
return yoke with some chambers around it
now I say I already said before the
experiment is a 100 meter underground so
all these major components is very heavy
components had to be you know lifted
down from the from the surface where
they were assembled so you see here one
of these wheels going down and this is
very habit you know arriving at the at
the bottom of the cavern where it is
then going to be assembled to the to the
CMS detector this is another photo of
you see here sort of the the part of the
magnet that we had seen before now it's
like all cable cabled up and everything
is connected and you see here a lot of
cables so one of the things that really
impresses it me is the amount of cables
that come out of the experimental hall
it's quite impressive
okay um let's see however time yeah I'll
do this very quickly um so you know the
the Large Hadron Collider collides
particles and a lot of you know
particles are created from the energy of
the of the beam and we use this huge
experiment detect these these particles
and then try to sort of recreate what
what happens in this initial collision
so I thought I'll show you a little
animation of how we sort of detect these
different kind of particles because even
so there is a lot of particles that are
created most of them a decay very very
quickly like inside the the vacuum pimp
pipe and there are only a few types of
particles that actually live long enough
that they are come out of there and sort
of can a traverse the detector so but as
shown here it's like a slice a slice of
the CMS detector and it's sort of like
you know a cross-section through the
detector and so let's say we have here
what is called a hoops where we
but it's called charged ahead run let's
say it charged okay sorry
so there are different detector
components so here is sort of what is
called a a tracker so this is something
if a particle a charged particle goes
through it at least is it leaves some
tracks there this is here what we call a
color emitter and it comes in two
variants a hetero neck color emitter and
electromagnetic calorimeter and you will
see in a moment what they are good for
this is the the magnet and then there
are some chambers out here that are
called immune chambers that I used to I
detect these muons the partners of the
of the of the electron okay so let's see
what happens if there is a charged a
hadron coming out of the initial
collision so what you see here is
several things first you see here this
it it loses most of its energy here in
this hadron a kilometer and it sort of
creates new particles and which are sort
of all recorded here the other thing
that you see is it gives some traces
here in this in this tracker
and the other thing that you see is it
the the the the pass of this a particle
is a curved and this is because it's a
charged particle in a magnetic field
always goes on a curved trajectory so if
we have then a neutral Hedren you will
probably very quickly see what the
difference is well the only difference
is it again you know loses all its
energy here in this pattern kilometer
but since it's a neutral it that it's it
just goes straight through and it does
not make any traces here in this trekker
component now if we take an electron so
electrons again a charge so it's a
curved a trajectory and the electron
loses all its energy in this
electromagnetic kilometer where the
Hadron adjust event went through now a
photon that we had talked about it is
sort of behaves like an electron it also
loses all its energy in the in this in
the electromagnetic color matter but
it's neutral so it goes just right
through and then finally we have these
neurons and they are charged so they are
on a curved track they go all through
the kilometer so they are not impacted
by that but then they leave a traces
here in these chambers that are out here
and just we call them a muon chambers
and you also see that you know it's
curved one way this here and one way out
here because there are two a magnetic
fields and they are opposite polarity
and so they go in a different direction
okay
all right so the next picture I wanted
to show you is to talk a little bit
about the science because I knew correct
would mention the dark matter so I
wanted to talk about a little bit about
that what do you see here well you see a
lot of where stars this is what is
called a Hubble ultra-deep field
exposure so this is a very very long
exposure taking with the Hubble Space
Telescope of a very very small part of
the sky it's like three arc minutes by
three arc minutes so this is really like
a tiny amount of the sky which is sort
of less than one millionth of you know
all this guy that is you know 4pi or all
around us now you can count how many
galaxies you you see here if you do that
you will count about maybe ten thousand
now we know each galaxy has about a
hundred billions of Suns in it and so
you can sort of quite easily then
calculate how many Suns are out there in
the universe you will get to a number of
something like ten to z22 to 10 to the
23 and if we sort of take you know the
average you know mass of our Sun you
will get you know a gigantic number of
how much matter is out there in the
universe
so it's really an enormous matter and/or
energy that's in the universe
however astrophysicists tell us this
only is 5% of the content of the of the
universe the rest is made out of 25%
dark matter that we heard about and then
more than a 70% of the universe is made
out of something that we call a dark
energy where we have actually no idea
what this what this really is I want to
quickly illustrate a little bit to you
so you know this dark matter it's a
called a dark matter because we cannot
see it so it means it doesn't are shined
like like a Sun so how do we know that
it actually is really out there and one
one evidence for the existence of dark
matter is illustrated here
this is what's called a rotational
velocity of galaxies so what what we
they want the person who were first sort
of discovered dark matter was a Fritz
Zwicky in the 1930s and he made
measurements of the of the velocity of
of stars in galaxies and so you know if
you sort of roll something around like
like a shot put the faster you go you
have to hold the more so because it's a
centrifugal force that once you know the
short put do it to fly away so now the
force that holds this galaxies together
is of course the gravitational force of
all the of all the stars that make up
this galaxy and so what was observed is
that the the stars out here in the in
the galaxies they they rotate way too
fast with this if the if the mass of the
galaxy just came from the mass of the
stars that hold this together you know
the the galaxy itself would sort of tear
itself apart and sort of just you know
fly and yeah tear itself apart so there
has to be more mass in this in this
galaxy and this more mass is what is our
dark matter okay
Dargis because we can't detect it and
but as I said we sort of can tell that
it's there from the effect that it has
on galaxies and it could be made out of
undiscovered
particles I'm not going to explain the
the picture here I want to sort of use
my remaining a few minutes to talk a
little bit about the connection between
dark matter and enter a particle physics
so particles can be candidates of dark
matter and so of course the first
thought that you have is you know all
the particles that we know about the
quarks and the leptons and neutrinos
maybe they could be this dark matter
well it turns out
that is not possible because their
masses are too too small especially the
neutrinos who were a candidate at some
point their masses is way too small to
make up the amount of dark matter that
is needed so a most prominent a
candidate is a particle that we do not
yet know about it and this candidate is
comes from a new theory which is called
supersymmetry now supersymmetry is
symmetry between fermions and bosons now
what are fermions and bosons so these
particles in addition to having like you
know something like a charge they also
have something what we call spin which
you can really imagine as like you know
the particle just whirls around and
spins around now in quantum mechanics as
you know a lot of a lot of quantities
are quantized so they are discrete so
these spins they come either as a an
integer number of the unit that they are
measured for which is Planck's constant
or they come in half integers so there
are particles that have a spin of 0 or 1
or 2 and we call them bosons and then
they're particles of where they are spin
off one half or three half and we call
them fermions and now it turns out most
of the particles that we have talked
about are quarks and our electrons they
are a fermions with a spin of 1/2 then
they're particles that we haven't really
talked about is which are the the ones
that mediate the different forces that
that we know and they are bosons and so
this supersymmetry postulates that for
every particle in our standard model
there is a partner particle a
supersymmetric particle and these
supersymmetric particles you know they
were created in the in the Big Bang they
existed you know in the very very early
universe when it was very very hot and
as we know you know the heavy particles
are usually decay into lighter ones and
then in the end there is one particle
that is going to be a leftover and this
is the lightest supersymmetric particle
and that is could be all the dark matter
that is out there in the universe and
these dark matter particles could for
example be produced at an accelerator
like the Large Hadron Collider there's
actually a good reason that the energy
at which the Large Hadron Collider will
operate that it will sort of produce
dark matter particles so this is
something that I'm interested in and
want to study very briefly to sort of
wrap this up last year September at
10:00 was the official start of CFC
Large Hadron Collider Google changed on
this day actually it's a logo to
something that resembles a Collider so
that was at a birth oh the first beams
went through the through the Large
Hadron Collider and they were sort of
just a dump and then there were a lot of
particles that sort of splash back and
these are some images from the CMS
experiment now you might have heard very
soon after that there was a accident at
the at the LHC that was sort of a kind
of an explosion which resulted from a
lot of liquid helium that was released
and so the the accelerator right now is
it's a repair is being repaired and this
is a delay for doing the physics so the
the magnets are right now replaced so
they had to replace about 50 magnets
which is not very much compared to the
1232 a magnets but you know it takes
some time to bring them up and down and
to now cable it all up and so the
program will resume in the late in the
late summer so I thought I'll stop I'll
end here with something so what do
physicists do in the mean time so I'll
give you a little idea here let's see
whether this works good morning and may
I welcome you on this auspicious day to
serve where we have the coffee expresso
research machine
well what we're hoping to do today is to
take hundreds and hundreds of volts
electricity and pass it through this
cable this thing goes deep into the
center of the machine where there is a
superheated coil we will then take water
and pump it through the superheated coil
at tremendous speeds tremendous speeds
and then what we're hoping to do is to
get a water particle to collide with a
coffee granule we were hoping we believe
that if we can get this collision to
take place in the collision chamber here
that we will actually create an express
them
I'll now just turn it on
hey it doesn't seem to work
all right thank you very much